[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  news  [Music]  so  [Music]  me  [Music]  bye  [Music]  ah  [Music]  huh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  two  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  max  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  x  [Applause]  [Music]  uh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Applause]  [Music]  thank  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  two  [Music]  [Music]  uh  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  so  [Music]  so  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  uh  [Music]  hey  [Music]  so  [Music]  now  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  wow  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  do  [Applause]  do  [Music]  oh yes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  oh yes  you